ce récit pourrait être inspiré d'un film
de science fiction
c'est pourtant une histoire vraie tu as
vu chez nous voilà au dessus de maple
est arrivé il était précédé noir iron
gilles andré thinel avec des groupes
c'était oui et tu mets les rouges quatre
personnes d'une même famille ont vu
l'objet de très près se stabiliser au
dessus du cerisier du jardin voisin
ce qui m'a beaucoup impressionné mois
ses grosses pattes grise métallique qui
se trouvait à l'extrémité de cet
appareil et cette lumière rouge qui
faisait le tour cet objet immédiatement
la famille prévient les gendarmes dans
la demi-heure deux brigadiers récolte
leurs témoignages comme le prévoit la
procédure dans les cas de détection
d'ovni
le témoin a dessiné ce qui lui semble
être la dimension de cet objet au dessus
de au dessus de l'arbre et on voit très
bien sur son dessin des formes un peu
bizarre de
en fait de l'ovni qui était qui était
observé dans le cas de voreppe
la solution est apparue au bout d'une
semaine quand la presse s'est emparée de
la sphère faisant affluer les
témoignages parmi les gens qui sont
venus nous trouver donc il y avait un
couple qui nous a fait savoir que à ce
jour là cette heure-là non loin du lieu
donc où étaient nos venir il avait perdu
un ballon gonflé à l'hélium en forme de
coccinelle l'histoire du ballon peu près
impossible kendall on a vu ce qu'on a vu
on peut pas croire ballon ballon mais je
pensais que ces quan ba un objet volant
non identifié au vasco